when I quit my full-time job I made less
than a hundred thousand dollars and I
lived with my parents in South
Philadelphia for five months and ended
up selling my car so I still haven't
gotten a car again I love every second
of it like like in those moments you
think I'm 32 and living at home with my
parents right it didn't bother me at all
because I I knew where I was going you
know I always talk about don't give a
[__] what they're saying you said
something right now that
say but not as clear as you just said I
know how this movie ends
I know what the scoreboard is going to
look like when it hits triple zero the
reason you didn't give a [__] at 32 is
the same reason I didn't give a [__] a
32 I knew where I was going